[MUSIC PLAYING]
ERIC ALEXANDER: It's
an honor to be here
and to be able to share this
story with all of you today.
And just like you said, my goal
is to encourage-- hopefully
to inspire you to overcome
the Everest in your own life.
And I've chosen
to actually title
this talk today, "Ascend!"
because we so often
maybe limit ourselves
in what's possible
for our lives.
And that's one reason I
love climbing with people
with disabilities-- because
when I see them challenge
themselves, I'm the one
who's encouraged and inspired
to go and live a
limitless life, myself.
And so it's to ascend.
It's to rise to the challenge of
what's possible for our lives,
and to live beyond limits.
How many of you have ever
maybe hit rock bottom?
You've set off for something.
You thought, this is the
direction I'm going to take.
This is the course.
Maybe it's literally
you've fallen.
Your climbers here,
your cyclists--
these types of things.
And maybe you've had
injuries or setbacks.
And so often, we let those maybe
define us or we get dejected,
and it's hard for us to kind of
regroup and set off and chart
a new course.
I had an experience like
this in the French Alps.
I had just finished
a year long exchange.
I had been ski patrolling.
I'd been learning the
language and working side
by side with these guys.
And I thought, what
a cool opportunity
I have here at the
end of the year
to go and do the Haute Route.
A bunch of patrollers were
coming from Beaver Creek,
up in the Vail area, and
they were going to join me.
We were going to do this week
long ski tour over the Alps,
and it was going to be awesome.
We get to the top of the tram.
We set off on day one.
We can see the
route ahead of us.
And we descend, and as we
descend, these clouds come in,
and they just totally
obscure our view-- the route.
We can barely see our ski
tips, it's that thick.
And it just came in like that.
And so we go across
this glacier,
and we lose sight of the route.
And we're trying
to find our way up,
and we keep kind
of scooting along.
And the next thing
we know, we're
getting spit out way
down the glacier.
How did we get so
far off course?
And we're just sitting
there all together,
talking about what's
going to happen next.
And we're completely bummed out.
The clouds lift.
The sun comes out.
It's now afternoon, and it's
too late to take the course
that we had charted.
And then up from below
comes this French guide--
a guy that I had gotten
to know that year.
And I can see his
face right away,
and he's kind of smiling
and singing songs.
And he sees us
there and he goes,
ah, Eric, in his French accent.
What are you doing?
And then we tell
him what happened.
And I'll never forget his
words, and I think of them
all the time because it was
simple, and in French, he said,
[SPEAKING FRENCH].
And it means, we don't
go down, we go up.
And he said, come with me.
We're going to go to this hut.
We'll get you back on course.
And that's all it took, was
just kind of that bright,
smiling face and the sunshine
to get us back on course.
Someone who maybe
believed or saw
the way that we couldn't see.
And so I've never forgotten
those simple words--
we don't go down, we go up.
And so climbing with people with
disabilities, I see that a lot.
I am this way.
I can't recover from this.
It's too late.
My life is over as I knew it.
The adventure is gone.
All possibilities-- all
the goals and dreams I had.
But then there's those rare few
who do see the possibilities.
One more example of this was
something growing up in my home
that my dad had brought home
that he won in a contest.
It was these pencil sketches.
The first one said, prepare,
and it showed these guys
getting their equipment ready.
The second picture-- and these
are giant, framed drawings--
was this, and it said, ascend!
And you can see this
is probably 1963.
I'm guessing it's the first
American expedition on Everest,
and he's got the oxygen mask
on and going up the lines,
heading up the mountain,
taking on the challenge.
And then the third
picture was triumph.
And there they are.
They've got the flag planted
on top of the mountain.
They've made it to the top
and there's celebration.
But the one I always choose
to focus on is this one--
ascend.
That's where the adventure is.
That's kind of the unknown.
It's where you have
to apply your strength
and your skill-- the
preparation's done,
and this is where the challenges
are-- the questions lie.
Will you make it?
Will you not make it?
Will you need to turn around?
And that's where so much
of our life is lived.
If we choose to take that step.
If we choose to believe.
If we choose to ascend
beyond our circumstances
or ascend towards our
dreams and our goals.
I've climbed around the world
with people with disabilities,
and I've seen this many times.
In one particular case, I
got to trek the Inca Trail
to Machu Picchu--
35 miles.
We did a special version.
We called it the Super Inca.
And we did 35 miles--
over 15,000 foot passes--
and we had nine blind high
school students on this trek.
It was amazing.
The scariest part
about it was that they
had nine sighted high school
students as their guides.
So you can imagine
how that goes.
They tune out to the
ear buds, which they
shouldn't have had anyways.
But the hat is pulled down.
It's like, oh, man,
this place is great.
And then there's a drop here,
and the leader takes a left
and forgets the guy behind him.
Can't see the turn--
ah, there's a drop.
But fortunately, we
travel in threes,
so there's always someone
behind to grab a backpack,
turn him, slap him on the rear,
and say, no, no, this way.
It's amazing to see how they
would take on that challenge,
and how their trust
and their camaraderie
would grow on the
days along the trail.
And the vision for what
was possible in their lives
would also grow as
they would ascend.
We got to Machu Picchu--
all of us, in one piece.
And when they got there,
they had special permission
to duck the ropes and go in
and touch these stones often
considered sacred
with their hands,
and run their hands on them.
And I thought this is
going to be amazing.
It's going to blow their minds.
They're going to
want to spend days
here, but after
about 10 minutes,
they were ready to go--
get a meal, shower
up, I don't know.
But what I realized
was it wasn't so much
the destination,
because one rock began
to feel just like another.
And to them, they couldn't
see it in its grandeur,
but it was just putting
their hands on the stone.
What it was for
them was the ascent.
It was the journey.
It was the camaraderie
that they had experienced,
the trust which they had
really never had to that level
or that degree in
their life back home.
And on this trip,
they got to experience
that in a really special,
unique, and different way.
Well, after the trip was over,
we're heading out on the train,
and four of these
students came up to me,
tapping their white canes
up the center aisle,
and they surrounded me.
And I thought oh, they're going
to beat me with their canes
because I've tortured
them over this last week.
Instead, they said hey,
this has been incredible.
Would you take us
to Kilimanjaro?
Wow-- that next year, I
saw four blind students
stand on the roof of Africa with
a completely new vision of what
was possible for their lives.
When we were done
with that, one of them
said, I'm going to get
an internship with NASA
and be the first
blind person in space.
Another one said, I'm going
to start a blind driving
school, a racing school.
Wait a second-- this
was before Google Cars,
you know, and all of that.
I don't know if
that's going to work.
He said, no, no, hear me out.
We go to the
Bonneville Salt Flats,
and as long as you go straight
you can go as fast as you want.
I don't know if it ever
got off the ground,
but I haven't heard of
any deaths out there.
But I admired his
passion, and it's just
amazing to see their eyes
opened up figuratively.
I have been able to
climb other places--
Aconcagua, Denali, Russia--
I got to go there
with my good friend
Erik Weihenmayer, who
lives here in Golden.
He's completely blind.
We climbed Mount Elbrus,
the highest point
on the European continent.
We would climb it blind and
make the first blind ascent,
but then we'd
click into our skis
and make the first blind ski
descent from 18,500 feet.
A lot of you ski, maybe
Winter Park here in Colorado,
and you've seen blind skiers.
Anybody seen that?
You're familiar with
maybe with how that works?
Maybe you doubt?
That's usually what
I've experienced,
is that people riding
on a chairlift will say,
well, they can see
a little bit, right?
No, not always--
completely blind.
So the way it works is
I yell at him a lot.
Or when he's not looking, which
is pretty much all of the time,
I give him a push and say
good luck and drop in behind.
It's a little bit that way,
but I stand beside him.
I describe the terrain.
It's gentle.
It's wide open.
There's no obstacles,
no trees, no rocks.
So you can pretty
much go for it--
make your first
turn to the left,
and I'll be right
there with you.
And so we'll take off, and I'll
say turn a left, turn a right,
and we'll make big, swooping
fast turns until the terrain
gets narrow and steep.
Then we slow down, and
it's more like a dance.
It's turn left, turn
right, turn left.
If there's something
he needs to know about,
I'll make sure he knows.
Hey, there's a rock
outcrop up there.
You might want to
slow down and put
on the brakes and
[WIPE OUT SOUNDS]..
No, no, no, he says.
I don't need to know what it is.
I just need to know what to do.
So it's better to
say stop, cliff.
There's really two things
you need in blind skiing,
and the first is trust.
The second, forgiveness.
Because you always do make
mistakes, or I do as a leader.
And so it's actually a
very important quality
that you have in a friend,
in a spouse, at work even,
and especially in blind skiing.
What I've learned
from my friend is
that he doesn't hold
that grudge against me,
because he knows it'll keep
us from achieving our goal.
It's more important
to focus on the goal--
fix the problem but keep
our vision up ahead.
And that's the way we do it.
So maybe you'd
like an opportunity
to guide a skier
down a mountain.
I'll give you that here.
So I've got a video.
Put yourself in my position.
You're going to lead this
person down the mountain.
So just kind of
hang on and think
about the lefts and the rights.
You don't have to shout
it out here in the room,
but just to maybe get
a feel for what that's
like, change your perspective.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Turn a left, turn a
right, turn a left.
Slow it down, there's a tree.
Slow down.
Stop, stop, stop.
[INAUDIBLE] with that helmet.
[END PLAYBACK]
How'd you do?
Yeah, OK, that guy is not blind.
But that's exactly what it feels
like, kind of out of control,
a little bit scary.
It's amazing.
That's why I'm so inspired
to see people do that
and to be a part of it
and to ascend and try
these things that are difficult
and challenge ourselves.
Another time I got to
do this was on Denali.
Climbing the highest
peak in North America,
I was able to take two
blind army veterans.
One was blinded in Iraq when
a suicide car bomb went off
right next to him.
He nearly lost his whole
head, and since then, he's
not seen the face of his
wife or has he ever seen
the faces of his children.
But he's thankful
everyday that he has life
and that he has those children.
And he still continues
to climb and to seek out
adventures in life, to ascend.
He's not going to be
defined by his disability.
He's going to be defined
by his ability to continue
to live a full life.
The other was Marty Bailey,
blinded in Afghanistan
when a grenade went
off in the foxhole
that he was in right next to
him, severed his optic nerve.
And it's the same for him.
He's seeking out
challenges professionally,
seeking out challenges
here in the mountains
to continue to
live a life that's
full of adventure, to ascend.
We came up just
short of the summit.
But again, it wasn't
about the triumph.
It was full of preparation.
But it was mostly about
the ascent, the challenge,
the obstacles, the struggle,
and doing this together.
I still climb.
Most recently, I was in
the Swiss Alps climbing
with my blind friend Erik.
And we chose to do one
of the six great north
faces of the Alps.
This one's called
the Piz Badile.
It's a 3,000 foot
wall of granite.
And we spent a lot
of time preparing,
getting trained
physically to do this.
We got to the Alps,
and you can see here,
this is a technique
called stemming.
But really, for
Erik, it's more about
brailling his way up the rock,
feeling where those holds are.
And so he'll be feeling for
a hold, and I'll say oh yeah,
it's right there, Erik.
It's just up eight
inches and over ten.
And then he'll feel for it.
And then he'll remember
right where that is,
and when he gets
up a little higher,
he knows his foot can
go right on that hold.
And so I'm there
climbing with him,
looking down between my feet,
guiding him as to where to go.
Well, at one point
on this climb,
it gets a little congested.
The weather had been
bad, and at this time,
everybody was charging the
mountain because it was finally
dry and the weather was good.
And so we thought, this is it.
This is our do or die moment.
If we continue on,
there's a good chance
we're going to spend the
night out on this face,
hanging from our harnesses.
If we go down, we're
probably not going
to get another shot at this.
What do we do?
We chose to continue to climb.
We followed our heart.
We followed our gut
and we pushed on,
about 13 hours of climbing, just
pure movement the whole day--
4:00 in the morning
till about 4:00 or 5:00
at night making the summit.
There's Erik celebrating.
I told him to give this
kind of corny pose,
you know, like the
double thumbs up.
But we were psyched
to have made it.
The next day-- we
didn't realize this
as we headed down into Italy,
but the mountain right next
to us, a twin peak
called Cengalo caved off
four million cubic meters
of granite, which went down
the valley and wiped out the
trail which we had hiked up,
wiped out the road
which we had driven up.
Our car was now stuck
in this parking lot,
high up on the mountainside
as this stone and mud and tree
and debris just
cleared the valley.
It went down and it wiped
out the Swiss village
where we started.
It had been
evacuated thankfully,
but eight people died.
And I was thinking, I am so
glad we didn't turn back,
that we followed our gut.
Eight tourists who were
trekking or climbing in the area
lost their lives to
that, and I think
we would have been among
them had we turned back.
I was thankful for the ascent.
I didn't realize it, but it
even made news here at home.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- At least eight
people are missing
after a massive landslide
in the Swiss Alps
that was caught on camera sent
mud, rocks, and dirt flooding
into a village near
the Italian border.
About 100 people had to be
evacuated from that area,
and now rescue crews
are using helicopters
to search for the missing.
[END PLAYBACK]
ERIC ALEXANDER: Sometimes it's
important to make a decision
to turn back.
Sometimes it's important
to continue on.
We don't always
know the outcome,
but we give it our best.
And in this case, I was glad
that we made the ascent,
that we chose to ascend.
Well, it's lessons I've
learned from climbing
that I apply to my life,
whether it's professionally
or to my family,
and again to climbs
that I continue to take on.
And that's what I want
to pass on to you.
What is it to ascend,
to make the ascent?
What does that require?
Well, it requires
the preparation.
But in the midst of it,
it requires courage,
for us to be courageous.
And I'd like to add
this little bit to that,
and that's the
courage to serve--
to look beyond ourselves
and our own needs,
to expand that to look out
to the needs of others.
One thing I love about climbing
with people with disabilities
is it requires that of me,
to forget about myself,
to put my attention on them.
And in doing that, the next
thing I know is my own fear
is gone because I've
taken it off of myself.
I've put it onto them and
we move along together.
My fears take a backseat.
My attention has
focused on them.
It takes faith and trust in each
other, a special team spirit.
We often hear the word teamwork.
And to me, teamwork is great.
It's getting the job done.
It's very task oriented.
But it's a little bit like an
engine which is just idling.
It's not going anywhere.
I like this word team spirit
because it is engaging.
It's what puts that car in
gear and uses that engine
to move the car down the road.
Leadership and integrity-- often
we hear the word leadership
and we think of it as if
it has virtue on its own.
But it's not until
the leader himself
has integrity and character
and is in that position
that this is true.
So leadership is great, but
it's having the integrity
which makes it matter.
And then lastly, perseverance--
the ability to go right back
up to the top of this list
and courageously serve again
and take another step forward.
I would learn this
really in the Himalayas,
because the greater the
challenge, the higher
the obstacle, the greater
the lesson, the more
we have to learn, the
more it can make of us.
I'd go to this
mountain here called
Ama Dablam on a training
climb with my friend
Erik, training for
Everest the next year.
We would climb up to
19,000, 20,000 feet together
through white outs, through
wind and cold and storm
while the team climbed ahead.
And at this point, I'm
super thankful for teamwork
because they've gone
ahead and set up camp.
Hey, that's awesome, teamwork.
I like this I can get into it.
Thanks, guys, for
carrying the heavy loads.
Which tent is ours?
To which they reply, uh,
yeah, you guys, you're
right over here.
Oh, thank you very little.
No problem.
I'm sure you're
thinking exactly what I
was-- my tent mate's blind.
He can sleep on the left.
He's also a lot quicker
and smarter than I am,
so he got in there and put
his stinky socks and underwear
all over the right hand side.
So I got the room with the view.
As we climbed into this tent,
the team went down to base camp
to get more supplies,
5,000 feet below.
And as they went
down, a storm came in
and it pinned us in this
tent together for six days.
Six days at 20,000
feet in the middle
of a storm in the Himalayas
with a blind climbing partner--
there is really
not a lot you can
do, except get to
know each other better
than you really ever wanted to.
So people always ask,
because the middle schooler
in us really truly never dies--
you're stuck there.
You're with someone who's blind.
You're eating.
You're drinking.
You sleep.
You have your coffee,
and then you know,
certain things need to happen.
And that'd be kind of rude.
I don't want to talk
about it, so I'll just
show you a picture of Erik
doing a bombing raid over Nepal.
That kind of puts an
end to that question.
So, you know, sometimes
you have to get creative,
innovative to find solutions.
The team came back up,
and it was a week later.
Our supplies were limited.
And we basically had one
shot at making the summit.
We gave it everything
we had, but the mountain
was coated in this thin layer
of ice and powdery snow,
and it just wasn't safe.
We're going to
have to turn back.
Incredibly difficult decision,
because we'd gotten sponsors.
We'd spent their money.
We'd traveled halfway
around the world.
People didn't believe in this.
There were naysayers,
and we were
going to have to
face those people
and say we didn't make it.
But I learned a lot about
success in this moment,
in this process.
So often we want
to define success
as standing on the summit
or planting that flag.
You know, maybe it's the house
you own, the car you drive,
the job you have,
the title you hold.
Those are fine, but they
don't define success.
In this moment, our
success was defined
by making the right decision.
This time, it was turning
back, which we needed to do.
It was not letting our pride,
I think most importantly,
get in the way of making the
right and the best decision.
And so we swallowed our
pride and we turned back.
One person made the
summit that year
from another team,
a Russian guy.
That Russian guy lost
all 10 of his fingers.
But our success was
defined by that decision,
not letting our pride
cloud that decision.
We communicated, we worked
through it, and we descended.
That was our success.
It was in the descent.
And so we worked our
way down the mountain.
And as we did, I got down to
our lower camp at 19,000 feet,
banging down these rocks,
rappelling down these ropes.
Then I had to unclip
from the fixed lines.
A few more steps, I
would be at my tent
on the edge of a 600 foot cliff.
I took this one last step, and
then the rock under my feet
flipped over.
The extra weight
in my pack I think
is what caused it to turn
like that, and I fell onto it.
And I landed on my chest,
and I grabbed the rock.
And as I did, it started
to slide over the edge.
My feet were dangling in space.
And I thought, if
I don't let go,
this rock is going to
crush me as I fall.
So I let go, but my gloved
hands couldn't grab the ledge.
And I started to
fall that 600 feet.
I'm often asked, well,
what were you thinking?
As if you can pause
in mid air you
know and formulate a
thought, like the coyote
and the roadrunner cartoons--
it's not like that.
I was thinking what anyone
would be thinking, and that is,
do these pants make me look fat?
No, it's four letter
words, you know the ones--
help, stop, grab, pray.
Well, maybe one or two
others slipped out.
And then it was a free
fall for a little while.
Then I hit a rock outcrop, and
I slid, and then another rock
outcrop, and 150
feet down I landed
on a ledge the size
of two of these chairs
on my feet with my eyes closed.
I thought I would open
them and see angels,
but instead I saw my
teammates looking down waving.
And I waved back, I'm not dead.
I kind of felt--
thinking I would feel my femur
sticking out, and I didn't.
I felt as though I'd landed
right in the hand of God,
and he said you know what,
it's not your day today.
I was so thankful.
I was even more thankful
for the rope that came down,
and my sherpa friend
that came down
with it to help me back up.
I got into the tent and
I was greeted by my tent
mate, who was an ER doctor.
A throwback to the '60s--
he said when I saw you
fall, all I could say
was whoa, man, stop.
My other teammate, this kind
of rough dude from Alaska,
he said dude, I thought
you were a goner.
Then he headed off to his tent.
Well, what about a hug?
My third teammate said, I
just started praying for you.
I felt as though his
prayers were answered.
But that night, my lungs
filled up with fluid.
My body was in shock
and I was getting
high-altitude pulmonary edema.
Thankfully, the ER
doc the next day
helped me down to base camp.
Together we'd make it
there, 5,000 feet below,
and I was finally put
in this thing here.
It could save my life.
In fact, it was a professor
here at CU that invented it.
It's called the
Gamow bag, and it
could save my life if my
teammates knew how to use it.
You can see he's reading the
instruction manual behind me
on just how this
might save my life.
I was so thankful
while I was in there
that I had people around me
that could help, that cared.
And at the same time, I
felt like the biggest loser
on the planet.
I shouldn't be the guy falling.
You can understand if
it's someone who's blind
who couldn't see that
rock, or you know, maybe
I misled him and said step
left, I mean right, ah.
But it was me.
I'm supposed to be reliable
and strong for my friend,
and this is it.
I'm not going to
Everest next year.
It's all over-- kind
of hitting the bottom.
The next day I was flown out.
A little hole opened
up in the storm.
A helicopter was able to land.
It was a Nepalese pilot
that risked his life
for mine, a complete stranger.
Talk about having the
courage to serve--
there was a guy
fulfilling the duties
that he wanted to when
he took his job, when
he took his position to
fly these helicopters.
It didn't require that he would
fly up in the midst of a storm,
but he did.
He risked his life for mine.
I went home and I
thought about this.
I contemplated it,
and I spent time
with this guy here, my best
friend, my climbing partner.
We'd scale the rocks.
Sometimes we'd even
get to a climb,
and we'd just be so engrossed in
a conversation we'd never even
get to climbing.
Before we knew it, it's
time, oh, we got to go--
just that kind of guy.
Joseph is a friend who
believed in me more
than I believed in myself.
He's the kind of friend that
I would wish everybody here
at some point in
their life would have.
Even better yet, a spouse like
that who believes in you more
than you believe in yourself--
an encourager.
When I told him I had my
doubts about climbing,
he said this is the
chance of a lifetime.
You've got to go back.
I'll go.
I'll carry your bags
if I can go, but don't
let this one pass you by.
I took that to heart,
because I was really
wrestling with fear and doubt.
That's what was keeping me
from wanting to ascend again.
I had hit rock bottom.
My pulmonary edema had turned
into a viral pneumonia.
It got infected
and I wasn't really
able to train for Everest,
and there's no way.
Well, then my friend went
missing in the East Vail
Chutes--
steep terrain outside
the area boundary.
He decided on this day
that he could do it alone.
He got overconfident.
One thing about the back
country is you never go alone.
You always have someone
there to watch your back.
He descended this steep chute,
came around a blind corner,
didn't see the cliff
that was there,
went over it, and 40 feet
below landed upside down.
It was the next
morning that I was
out with my friends on the
ski patrol looking for him,
hoping to find him in a snow
cave or something with just
a broken leg.
I'll never forget peering down
over the edge of that cliff
and seeing his snowboard
staring back up at me.
We went down and
we dug him out and.
And it was just way too late.
He had suffocated.
He was frozen and he was dead.
Now it was two months before
the climb of a lifetime,
and I full of grief
and missing my friend.
And I went to his memorial
and his funeral back
in Pennsylvania,
where he grew up.
And I stood beside his casket.
And next to it I saw his
yearbook, and in that yearbook
was a picture of him.
And the question was, what are
you going to do with your life
after you graduate?
And the other students
on that same page
had answers that we all
would recognize, you know,
I'm going to go to this school.
I'm going to get this job.
I'm going to spend
my summer doing this.
And then there's Joseph.
This was his response--
"My plans are to
make a difference
in the world around me."
Not many high school kids
have that perspective.
I thought about that.
That's exactly who he was.
That's how he was
living his life,
and that's what I want to do.
I might honor my friend and at
least explore this opportunity,
so I'm going to do that.
And as a Christian,
I'm a person of prayer,
so I prayed through it.
And I was kind of letting
fear control that.
And so I prayed
that way, like yeah,
let's just slam
these doors shut.
Let's do that.
That's the way I want it.
I'm afraid.
I don't want to go
back on that mountain.
So I'm going to see a
pulmonologist in Boulder.
This guy is a specialist.
He's going to give me
that pink slip, which
I can show the team.
And so I went and
saw him and he said,
you know what, if
you're careful,
I don't see why
you can't go back.
[SIGHS] That's
not what I wanted.
OK, well I'll go ask the
team, because they're not
going to say yes.
Not one of my teammates said no.
Nuts, we don't have
the money for this.
Just as those words
left my mouth,
we got a $250,000 donation
from the National Federation
of the Blind.
Of all organizations to
sponsor a climb like this,
it was a blindness organization
that believed in us
and put their neck on the
line to support this climb.
I got one last chance.
So I asked my friend Erik,
and I said, hey, you're blind.
You don't want another
gimp taking you
to the top of the world.
What do you think?
I'll never forget his response.
He said, being blind,
my whole life people
have made judgments about me,
what I can and what I can't do.
I'm not about to do
that same thing to you.
You've got to
decide for yourself.
Oh, I realized, yeah,
you'd be a hypocrite
if you'd said anything
else, but I would sure
wish you would have said no.
I'd be OK.
I thought about it for a minute.
I said, all right, Erik, I
don't know if I'm strong enough
to get to the top.
But I know I'm strong enough
to help you get there.
And so if you'll
have me back, I want
to see you stand on
top of the world.
So again, leaning
on my faith, I would
take these words to
heart, where it says,
"Be strong and courageous.
Do not be afraid.
Do not be discouraged."
So I took that.
"Be strong and courageous,"
sure, for my own sake,
but for his sake too.
Maybe it's just base camp.
I'll get there, and
then I'll break it down.
Camp one, we'll get there.
Well, when word got out that
we were going to Everest,
that a blind man
wanted to summit,
we had naysayers, people who
thought, this is impossible.
A blind person doesn't belong.
He's going to die.
They tell me he's going
to take you with him.
Our response is, well,
that's great, Mom and Dad,
but really, we
have what it takes.
And it was people close to us
that were concerned, of course,
but it was the elite
Himalayan veterans,
names that if I was to
tell you, you'd recognize.
And what we'd learned was
that these guys are experts,
but we're the
experts on ourselves.
They have not climbed
with someone who's blind.
They don't know
what an athlete you
are, what experience you
have, what you're capable of.
We can make this ascent,
so let's take that step.
And there we are,
back in the Himalayas,
making this 30-mile
trek to base camp,
climbing right in
front of Ama Dablam,
the mountain I had fallen
off the year before.
Along the way, we would have two
other blind trekkers with us.
So we had Erik, who's
climbing, and then
what we called our alternates
in case he fell on a crevasse.
They didn't think
that was so funny,
but they called themselves the
three blind mice as we'd go up.
And so the sherpas,
they're part of our team.
Our success really depends
on them, and especially
their belief that
this can happen.
And so as we're
trekking in, they said,
those guys are blind.
They're off the trail.
They're needing breaks.
They're not so good
with the tools.
But that guy, he's fast.
It's almost like he can see.
And so they thought we were
up to something, you know,
this is a hoax.
And so they're
going to prove it.
And so they'd come up to Erik
as we're going down the trail.
And this was for days on
end, and just kind of whew,
you know, he's going
to flinch this time.
I'm going to get him.
We're going to show him.
They'd set up like
these little tricks.
Erik, man, our
team is splitting.
You've got to tell them your
story, something, because this
isn't going to fly.
So we'd get up high, and one
of our dining tents-- you know,
it's below freezing.
Breath is rising.
Sunburned faces,
puffy coats are out.
There's a candle on the table.
The wind is blowing-- you know,
something kind of like out
of an Indiana Jones movie.
It's this surreal moment.
And the lead sherpas come in.
This is it.
The tissues are there for
when the tears start flowing.
Tell your story, Erik.
And instead of saying a
word, he comes into the tent
and he just goes
[PLUCKING SOUNDS],,
pulls out his prosthetic eyes,
and looks around the room,
and puts them back in.
My team's response was
just like the sherpas, uh--
please do not do that again.
We believe you.
That next morning, they were
at his tent first, you know,
let me help you.
Here's your tea.
Some extra sugar?
Let me take your backpack.
Sometimes, it takes a little
bit of innovation, and again,
a dramatic moment to get people
on board and on the same page.
And that's what happened.
So there we are.
Now we're a cohesive team.
We're ready to set
off on the climb.
We've made it to base
camp, 18,000 feet.
The climb truly
begins in earnest
here as you go up through
the Khumbu Icefall,
this river of ice flowing
down from Nuptse, Lhotse,
and Everest.
Hundreds of meters deep,
crumbling, moving--
many people have lost
their lives here.
The avalanche most
recently, I think
it was 18 people
that were killed,
and then the year
before, 15 sherpas
were killed when ice
came down on them.
It's not a place
you want to linger,
that you want to move slow.
You've got to be quick.
Our first time through that
icefall took us 13 hours.
I thought, the
climb is not going
to happen if we can't get
through here more quickly.
We're too exposed.
As time went on,
our time came down,
and we were able to
eventually cut that in half.
Well, what I did see as we
began our ascent was not just
the courage to plan, to
prepare, but the courage
to ascend, to put our feet to
the ground and make it happen.
You'll see that in
this little video clip
that I have of Erik stepping
on this first ladder crossing.
It had never been done
before, first blind person
to summit Everest.
So what do you do
about the ladders?
You can't see, and they're
not perfectly level.
They're not OSHA approved.
They lay on their side.
They're missing rungs.
They're bent.
They're damaged.
They bounce.
Courage, it's defined
as facing danger
with confidence and control.
I think a better
definition is that it's
the mental and moral
strength which propels us
in the presence of fear, because
the fear doesn't go away.
Hopefully it can just sit in the
back seat as you move forward.
So put yourself in these shoes.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[PANTING]
[END PLAYBACK]
ERIC ALEXANDER: That's courage.
And it's not just one time.
It's continual.
But thankfully, there's a team,
because not at every moment
are you that person
who's leading the charge,
or who's full of courage
and ready to be the leader
and rise up.
We need each other.
We need a team.
We need that trust.
And what is that trust made of?
As I see it, I've broken it
down into these components.
Trust is reliance.
You have trust
because you've proven
yourself reliable over time.
It's competence, that
you've shown and proven
that you belong because you
have the skills required.
On this mountain, there
are so many people
who are really incompetent, who
don't have the experience, who
don't belong there.
They rely completely on the
experience of someone else,
most likely their guide.
It's commitment, that you're
committed to each other.
Again, you show that over time.
You prove yourself.
And then lastly, that
leads to confidence.
Having those things give you
confidence in each other.
With all of that,
you then have trust.
This team had trust
like no other,
like no other on the mountain.
In fact, at first
when we arrived,
people said avoid those guys.
They're going to be a problem.
But by the end, people
were rallying around us
because we had proven ourselves
to be so trustworthy and so
competent on the mountain that
they wanted to be a part of it,
and that we could support
each other, collaborate.
And that's what team spirit is.
Team spirit transcends
teamwork, because it
maximizes the
individual's strengths
towards a common goal.
It's collaborative and
it's focused on others.
That's what made our team
so different from any other,
because we had this blind
person who they thought
was a weak link, who was
actually the glue that held us
together in an unlikely way.
I like this saying, where it
says, "Two are better than one,
because they have a good
return for their work.
If one falls down, his
friend can pick him up,
but pity the man who falls and
has no one to help him up."
You think, that's great.
You're always picking Erik
up because he's blind.
He's tripping and falling.
But it was actually
my blind friend
who picked me up,
who believed in me
and saw the possibilities for
me as much as I did for him.
An unlikely pair,
but with that pair,
we made a good team because
we were there for each other.
He was there for me when he
said yeah, come back and climb.
He was also there for me when
it's 4:00 in the morning.
It's dark, windy,
below zero outside,
and I hear his
crampons on the ice.
He's ready to go.
I'm still in my sleeping bag
trying to get every second I
can out of the warmth
that's in there,
and I realize he needs me.
He can't climb without me.
It's time to move on.
He's picked me up.
We're ready for the ascent.
And so we continue to
climb from the icefall.
Now it's on to the Lhotse Face--
this 3,000 foot wall of ice,
45 to 70 degrees in steepness,
ice falling, rocks
tumbling down, cascading.
We'd set up camp here at
24,000 feet before we'd
turn the corner and go
over the yellow band.
And then the Geneva Spur.
Finally, ending at
26,000 feet, a place
called the Death Zone, where
you can't survive long,
even with supplemental oxygen.
It takes a whole team just
to set up the camp.
As the wind is blowing
30 to 50 miles an hour,
the temperature is
consistently below zero.
One guy holds the tent while
one sticks the poles up through,
throwing the gear in
and then tying it down.
At this point, you
know that this is it.
This is where the climb
really will happen.
We still have what it takes.
The team, we start to look
at each other with kind
of like this laser
beam like vision.
You can almost see right
through each other.
Can I still trust you now?
Because this is where
it really matters.
Just steps away
from our tent, we
see the body of a sherpa
who died years before,
but he's still there frozen
to the ground, perfectly
preserved-- a guy who died
with all of his senses,
and we're still trying
to bring a guy up who's
missing a critical one of his.
Well, the team decides
to continue on.
9:00 at night, without
really saying a word,
we form a single file line
and we continue the ascent.
Just the night before,
an Austrian climber
had fallen to his death
when an old rope snapped.
A Russian climber fell to
his death on the north side.
Fear and doubt again
have us in its grip.
But with that team spirit,
with the kind of trust we have,
feeling good enough, we
take those steps forward.
A couple hours in, our
team leader turns back--
a guy who had submitted
Everest before,
one of the strongest
climbers on our team.
He's coming down.
He gets to me.
He lifts his
goggles and he's got
a tear running down his cheek.
And he says, I've
got nothing left.
My feet are frozen.
I've got to go back.
I thought for sure
he's going to just say
and we're all going back.
If I don't have it, chances
are you don't either.
We're going back.
But in that moment, I learned
a lot about leadership,
because this guy had the
original vision along with Erik
to make this climb happen.
And I that's what leadership
is, is it's visionary.
And it believes in that vision.
It takes action upon it.
And then most
importantly, it's built
on a platform of character.
He didn't let his pride
get in the way once again.
And his character said, you
guys have what it takes.
I'm not going to push so hard
that I get myself in trouble
and bring you down with me.
I'm going to pass the baton
and say you guys go for it.
That's what good
leadership does.
So we continued on
into the darkness
where at one point
in a white out,
I couldn't see my hand
in front of my face.
The guy behind me said, I
haven't seen mine in 20 years.
Keep going.
All right.
And so we keep moving forward.
The white out gives
way to the stars.
The stars soon give
way to the sunrise.
And though we can't
feel the heat,
we feel that warmth of hope,
that this might just happen.
What people said was impossible
we're going to pull off.
We get to the Hillary Step.
And Erik reaches out
and grabs one old rope.
I see that this is where a
guy died the night before.
And I yell at Erik,
don't grab one.
Grab all those old ropes.
He does.
He gives it a yank and a kick,
and like that, again traveling
in threes, we get up
over the Hillary Step,
and a few more
steps to the summit.
Perseverance, the last in my
list of requirements to ascend.
That's having a
passion for what you
do, a faith in its purpose,
a willingness to take a risk,
and then the mental
stamina to persist in it.
With that, you can persevere
and stand on top of the world.
We spent about 15
minutes up there.
This team that was supposed
to go down in flames
set five world records.
As the sherpas called him, the
blindest man in the world, Erik
stood on top.
Sherman Bull was
on our team, 64.
At that time, he
became the oldest man.
It was his fifth attempt.
He said, I didn't plan to be
the oldest man to climb Everest.
I just got old trying.
His son, Brad Bull, who
lives here in Colorado,
was part of our team.
So they joined and they became
the first American father
and son.
At the time, we also
had the largest camera
to stand on the summit,
a 25-pound HD camera.
But the one I'm most proud of is
that we were the largest team.
19 of us stood on top.
The reason that is
is because we all
had that common belief
and that glue of Erik
uniting us to get to the top.
Erik made the cover of "Time"
magazine a couple weeks later.
And I'm not at all
bitter or jealous
that I'm standing right there.
You can see a rope
tied to his waist.
Well, in this picture,
that rope goes to me.
But that's not why I
signed on, you know,
it's just celebrating
that success with him.
An invitation in New Zealand to
stop by the home of Sir Edmund
Hillary--
we got to spend
the day with him.
We talked about five
minutes of climbing,
and the rest of the time it was
about philanthropy and giving
back, and what's next,
and what are you doing?
How are the schools?
How are the hospitals?
Great to be with one
friend and two heroes.
Also, an invitation
to the Oval Office
to meet former President Bush.
So to be here this
afternoon to talk to you,
it's to encourage
you, to challenge
you and myself to
ascend, to not give up
on those dreams and the
possibilities that you see,
or maybe those friends
that believe in you more
than you believe in yourself,
that they see for your life.
To apply these principles
and to challenge yourself
to take that next step towards
that summit, whether it's
a mountain, a physical
summit, or whether it's
right here in this building.
So thanks for your time today.
I want to wish you all the best.
Thanks for your time.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: So the first question
is from Dave [? Minago. ?]
I don't know if--
Dave, are you here by chance?
OK, I'll go ahead and
ask it for him then.
I understand the cost
of this expedition
can cost tens of
thousands of dollars.
How would you recommend folks
trying to climb something
like this in the future begin
to finance this expedition?
Sponsorship, or--
ERIC ALEXANDER: Yeah,
that's a great question.
Sponsorship gets
harder and harder
to find as the climb
has become so popular.
A lot of people
do it, and so what
makes you different or unique?
So if you're going
that route and you're
going to find sponsors,
I think to finance
this you kind of really
have to have something that
sets your climb apart
and unique, whether it's
a new route or something
that's not been done before,
in a winter without oxygen--
you know, you've got to kind of
push the boundaries if you're
going to get a sponsor.
Otherwise, work hard, raise
the money, sell your car.
Yeah, go up the north side.
It's a little less expensive.
You can figure out ways.
Get the skills required.
You don't need to pay guides.
Try to get a private expedition.
Just hire some sherpas.
Keep your team to the minimum.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: All right.
What are your thoughts
on the long standing
question of commercialization
of the seven summits,
and should people
have to qualify
to climb those mountains,
almost like a marathon,
or should the mountains
always be open to everybody
who wants to try them?
ERIC ALEXANDER: That's
a tough one to answer.
To me, the mountains
really represent freedom.
And I think people should be
free to go and to attempt it
and to try it, but there
are those prerequisites.
And some people lack
the judgment to say,
I don't have those skills yet.
I don't own it.
And on Everest, for example, you
have to send in an application,
but it comes with a check.
And I think all they really
do is take the check,
toss the application, and
yeah, you're good to go.
You've driven Mount Evans,
that's good enough for us.
You're ready.
So the commercialization,
it's great for the guides.
They get to make a living
doing what they do.
They get to use their expertise.
They get to kind
of shepherd people,
protect them, keep them safe.
But I think there's
limits to that.
And some people get greedy
and push those limits.
So it's a mix.
I'm mixed on it.
I don't have the
answer or the solution.
SPEAKER 1: Fair enough.
We'll take a live question.
Somebody will-- and just
go ahead and speak it
as loudly as you can.
AUDIENCE: And sorry
I missed this,
but I was curious how exactly
you involved in the beginning
with helping people either hike
or climb with disabilities?
ERIC ALEXANDER: I live
up in the Vail area,
and I grew up
skiing Winter Park.
And so I saw people
with disabilities skiing
all the time, you
know, with one leg
cranking through the
moguls, and blind skiers,
and I was always
inspired by that.
And so after college when
I went up to live in Vail,
I got involved and started
volunteering in the blind ski
program.
And I enjoyed it.
And I guess I've
always just gravitated
to those people with
physical challenges.
And so they tend to
just cross my path.
In terms of Erik, I was
living with a friend who
was in a wheelchair,
and he invited Erik
over after skiing
together at a conference,
and that's how I met Erik.
He crashed on our couch,
started talking about climbing,
and then one thing
led to another,
and were on Mount Everest.
SPEAKER 1: Just like that.
Any other questions
from the audience?
Otherwise I have a
few more in here,
and then we'll wrap it up.
As a non-disabled climber,
what was your biggest challenge
to overcome summiting Everest
and the other tallest peaks,
and then for a climber
with disabilities,
what did you witness being
their biggest challenge?
ERIC ALEXANDER: My biggest
challenge, especially
on this peak, was
fear and doubt,
and figuring out that path,
navigating fear and doubt,
and not letting it overwhelm me.
And I think that was a big one.
And really what helped is
having a team, a supportive team
around me to overcome that.
And then like I
said earlier, too,
is having the courage
to serve someone else.
And when you put your
focus on somebody else,
you see their problems
that you're helping with,
and you forget yours.
And so I saw that ladder
as an example of this.
You know, my first step
was like shaky knees,
Elvis leg, you know, I
don't want to do this.
I don't trust it.
But then I see Erik just kind
of coming right up behind me.
Next thing you know, I'm
walking across backwards
because I'm focused on him.
So that's the way that goes.
So that was my challenge,
was fear and doubt.
The physical part
wasn't so hard.
For people with
disabilities, I think
I can relate to them,
because a lot of times
it's the same thing.
It's the unknown.
And so that tends to
bring out fear in us.
Their fear I think
is best overcome
by developing that trust and
that relationship over time.
Otherwise, sometimes it is
just flat out the physical.
Yep, that same buddy
that used to be
my roommate in a wheelchair, he
climbed Kilimanjaro on a hand
cycle with arms like this.
His arms are bigger
than my legs,
such a stud, just hand cycling.
So what's the challenge there?
Well, it is the physical.
How do we get your wheelchair
up this narrow trail
with lava rock and all
this, but there's a way.
You've just got to be smarter.
SPEAKER 1: Awesome,
unbelievable.
Did you have one quick one?
Go for it.
AUDIENCE: Hopefully quick,
and future aspirations
by yourself or with Erik?
ERIC ALEXANDER: Any
future aspirations?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ERIC ALEXANDER: Uh, are
you going to tell my wife?
He just had a hip
replacement in July
and we went out and did
a 10-mile hike last week.
So he's on the road to recovery.
We want to go back
to Ama Dablam.
Yeah, so that might
happen in the fall.
Not this fall, we're a
year out so he can recover.
And then he just
said, let's go ski
across the ice
sheet in Greenland,
which is a 30 day polar trek.
So there's that, and--
SPEAKER 1: Unbelievable.
ERIC ALEXANDER:
--it's a never ending
like, what else can we do?
So yeah, there's
plenty of things.
SPEAKER 1: Awesome.
ERIC ALEXANDER: Actually, I
want to go to the Rubicon Trail
with my blind friend
Scotty, the Iraq veteran,
and let him drive.
It's a four wheel
drive Jeep thing,
but it's so slow I
think he could do it.
SPEAKER 1: You should call
the high school student--
ERIC ALEXANDER: I should.
SPEAKER 1: --that
was interested.
ERIC ALEXANDER: I should,
I thought about that.
Yeah, call the kid.
SPEAKER 1: There you
go, there you go.
Well, thank you for
sharing your story with us.
Thank you guys for coming.
Round of applause.
ERIC ALEXANDER: Yeah, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]